my gift to you it is a wedding gift I am
a you know open it up
see what it is cozy is for when you're
watching drag race with Miley who are
these people this is oh it's me it's me
my wife that's great
to be wife husband and wife it's the
best it's the best you know I feel so
lucky to be with someone like there is
such a big night for you these who've
your people and to receive this honor
what does this mean I was just saying I
get kind of embarrassed about getting
awards for for acting I don't know
because I feel already so so privileged
to do something that I love so much and
you know it's such a great position to
be in but I'm you know I'm very thankful
and very grateful to receive this award
it's it's really cool Vince is
presenting to you you just finished your
movie Arkansas together why is he the
guy I love Vince so much you know I mean
that's someone that I've looked up to
for a long time
I think that that's probably one of the
coolest parts about tonight is the fact
that Vince has taken the time to come
and give me this award and you know it's
I don't know it's just great to be up on
a stage with Vince and to be able to
call that person my friend and then you
know someone that I've worked with it's
just I feel very very lucky to be in the
position I'm in
[Music]